zéro des semences ont disparu et
l'humanité est en danger réalité non
fiction et scénario de base de l'escape
games organisés par l'open agri food
pour redorer le blason de la filière
agroalimentaire
un jeu qui met les connaissances des
candidats à rude épreuve
je pense que pour les enfants aussi ça
peut être très diversifiant de deir re
découvrir à partir d'un à partir d'une
énigme à partir d'une enquête de
redécouvrir en fait l'alimentation en
elle même est en fait c'est très très
ludique pour pour l'essence chercher
découvrir slogan de lopins agri food
produire ce un bon peu cher et pour tout
le monde
en résumé promouvoir le sandwich de
grandes surfaces et en même temps le
kilo de carottes bio c'est un moment
aussi des changes mais aussi
d'informations pour puisqu'on a des
tables rondes
on va avoir des ateliers pour
co-construire aussi est exposé des
propositions qui vont être omis
justement au gouvernement donc on
souhaite partir de la communication pour
aller vers l'action nous allons pouvoir
sauver l'humanité sauver le monde
une belle idée qui reste encore à mettre
en pratique